[Музика]
привіт, мене звуть Наталія, і я ваш
учитель англійської мови на попередньому уроці
ми запам'ятали багато слів про спорт
ми говорили про зимовий вид спорту літні
види спорту в приміщенні спорт на відкритому повітрі ми
навчилися використовувати гру, або робити зі спортом  ми
знайшли дуже дивні види спорту, як-от собачий
серфінг або шаховий бокс, і ми створили
навіть свій власний вид унікального виду спорту,
як-от паперовий м'яч, тому я дав вам
домашнє завдання, давайте перевіримо його, ви повинні
виправити помилки, подивіться на ці
речення і давайте виконаємо це  разом
давайте займатися плаванням після школи, де
тут помилка, що ми маємо
це сказати  правильно займатися боксом наступного минулого
літа, вони займалися серфінгом в Іспанії, що
ми тут відчуваємо, так, займалися серфінгом,
тому що це було минулого літа, наступного дня вона
займалася аеробікою щоранку, тому що їй
подобається танцювати,
що вона робить помилкою
аеробіка щоранку так, ти маєш рацію,
вона робить, і останній
погляд вони ходять на хокей без шоломів, це
небезпечно, що це помилка, що ми повинні
додати, вони грають в хокей так, ви праві,
добре, тому сьогодні ми поговоримо про
найпопулярніший вид спорту  у світі та в
Україні так що це за вид спорту
хм так це футбол на
початку я хотів би пояснити
різницю між цією картинкою на цій
картинці це футбол і це
теж футбол але вони різні
це футбол ми його називаємо  іноді футбольний
і навіть фруктовий, а це американський
футбол зовсім інша форма
м'ячів різна форма пам'ятайте, що це
не те саме далі зараз я скажу вам кілька
нових слів і фраз про футбол,
спробуйте вгадати їх значення і повторіть,
хтось грає у футбол, це
футболіст або  футболіст футболіст повторюю
для мене футболіст футболіст ми використовуємо
кулінарний м'яч Плюс це закінчення, і у нас є
людина, яка грає у футбол поруч із
групою футболістів, які  o грає разом команда
чиста команда група гравців, які грають
разом це команда скільки
гравців у футбольній команді
скільки хто знає так
у футбольній команді 11 гравців це
збірна Англії Чемпіонат світу з футболу 2018
скільки гравців 11 добре  переміщати м'яч
з їжею переміщати м'яч з їжею
- це кинути м'яч удар по м'ячу ми не
б'ємо по м'ячу ми не кидаємо м'яч ми
б'ємо м'яч у футболі запам'ятовувати,
коли м'яч потрапляє в сітку  сітка воріт
ви забиваєте іди забивай гол забивай
гол гравець, який стоїть у сітці воріт
йти воротар іти воротар іти воротар повторити
ще раз удар по м'ячу забити
гол воротар і тепер дивись Роналду
б'є м'яч і забиває
гол  nooooo pitch
atta boy воротар пропустив м'яч, але
наш воротар запропонував мені achar ну
я ніколи не знав я добре знав я ніколи не б'ю
м'яч голкіпер забиваю гол
перейти далі
подивіться на це фото стадіон це
місце, де спортсмени грають футбольний
стадіон це  будівельний стадіон, але
це футбольне поле або футбольне поле
ця зелена частина стадіону з
травою, зазвичай з травою, це футбольне
поле або футбольне поле добре
студія люди, які підтримують обробку
або підбадьорюють уболівальників гравців або
вболівальників Reuters або Reuters вірять у нашу шию  вище
смішно піти, щоб піти на чай
бульвар є співведучим хто ти збираєшся
на бульвар Кабуто
я йду на Нама, шеф Бразилії
підбадьорює когось
cp3 рухатися яка неслухняна красуня підбадьорити
когось кілька слів для підбадьорення
давай,
давай, дивись із раціонального,
краще підійти до кімнати будь непогано непогано
ура, ці старі фрази для підбадьорювання
футбольної команди стадіон
повний уболівальників подивіться на ці фотографії
стадіон повний уболівальників порно якщо анатомія
вони  підбадьорити команду, коли
командос Петрі настрій Олле Олле
Олле відомий підбадьорення вболівальників Олі Олі
Олі ми чемпіони добре, давайте йти
далі і матч у футбол,
іноді матч грі  t перемога в матчі
знову перемога означає завершення матчу з
кращим рахунком з кращим рахунком
Сара, яка стукає,
щоб бути над королями, що цей фініш закінчився,
гра закінчилася ви знаєте це слово
гра закінчена і трофей трофей трофей у
вас є трофей  приз за перемогу,
коли ви виграєте гру, закінчився
Резак у Китаї, це був чудовий матч -
фантастика Снайві Кім багато динамічно
виграла Єва - Ніл трофей наш динамічний,
навіть ми Херлі Кубек Неш Верна - vaho
we Cosmo - Ніл без інших слів
без зайнятості в рукаві трофей
наш Кубек Неш, а тепер давайте подивимося на
деякі футбольні правила.
bow vitami a cha, коли ви б'єте
м'яч у сітку воріт, колонка
дивитися Papa Papa
daya rota на футбольній
сторінці Nepali
right ordinate experts - гра закінчена
через 90 хвилин 90 хвилин, ви не повинні
торкатися  м'яч рукою не можна
торкатися м'яча руками ім'я
Osnes Sabourin anoter katisa me atcha
Rock'em ok atta boy / devo Musa побудував
vajna na Gromit кожну хорошу вантажівку Торі
давайте дивитися, як бабуся дивиться, Роналду
б'є м'яч, який ми використовуємо тут тепер
безперервно  час теперішній безперервний
час що це хто пам'ятає це
описує те, що відбувається зараз що
відбувається зараз у момент розмови
seiches сподіваємось ми говоримо GU jakob Ovadia pre
amo
Zara's moment Oh Varinia present continue
now я стою та маю
урок англійської мови зараз ти дивишся
Урок англійської мови на вашому телевізорі
yuck we for muy mas H s як ми створюємо
дієслово-час, щоб бути з дієсловом і в кінцівках,
наприклад, ви дивитеся онлайн
урок англійської мови, зараз ви дивитеся, я
стою в теперішньому тривалому часі,
опишіть дію, яка відбувається
тепер запам'ятайте це, тому це дуже
корисно для перегляду футбольних матчів, коли
ми дивимося футбольний матч, ми описуємо,
що відбувається на екрані, добре, а тепер
давайте потренуємося  добре, давайте потренуємося,
тому що англійська я впевнений, що це теж
спорт, і нам потрібно тренувати свої навички добре,
ми повинні поставити це дієслово в правильній формі
давайте дивимося гру зараз я ставлю їх так
багато давайте дивитися гру підшкірний покрив
кімнати збірна Бразилії так  ти маєш рацію
, граєш у Бразилії, заратос,
звичайно, так, Китай
номер 2, що ти зараз робиш, знімай, це
Арис, сміття, що ти робиш зараз,
поліція, так, caboodle, так, ти маєш рацію,
я дивлюся футбольний матч
так, Zara вільний  футбольний матч
я дивлюся футбольний матч далі ми
маємо його розташування ах
уявіть собі ситуацію, чи не можете ви мені допомогти,
будь ласка,
Морріс, багато хазарів ДіПальма зараз, чи можете ви
допомогти мені, будь ласка,
ні, я не можу Ян аморальний Томоко Муша
Уманья гіроскоп Зара зловмисний вереск Я  я
маю онлайн-урок англійської зараз, вибачте,
наступного разу надайте мою
лебідку для завантаження Amazon, зупиніться, чому я говорю так
повільно, чому вони так повільно біжать, щоб
рухатися, будь нею ти говориш, Поліна, чому
вони так повільно біжать,
я не можу цього витримати  Дж  anna motor
Ванесса спокуса додати більше моторного
центру PT / найкращі лікарі Девід Седаріс
футбольна магія футбольне ім'я футбол без
гуру коментар - EEE
хтось дивиться гру та коментує,
чому вони так повільно бігають,
і останній
погляд подивіться рефері друга Б.
червона картка йому О ні, я ніколи не
пудель є судах Пікассо йогі Месзарос
сервопривод новий автомобіль CUDA вона, мабуть, у голові, що крутиться в
океані, погода показує йому червону
картку, тому ми використовуємо тут
теперішній безперервний час, хороший у парі,
а тепер ви повинні сказати  мені правда чи неправда
Prada Абу новий Prada альбом гепарда
сітківка біміні дієта VIP із цього скажи
правду Чейні Прабха
правда чи неправда першим є шість
гравців у футбольній команді правда чи
неправда, тому що
скільки гравців у футбольній команді
так  наступні 11 гравців у футбольній
команді, ви повинні торкатися м'яча
руками у футбольній грі, звичайно, ви
не повинні торкатися м'яча руками у
футбольній грі, це правда чи неправда
це правда, це одне з футбольних правил,
тому приємно подорожувати футбол наступний шаховий
бокс - найпопулярніший вид спорту
в усьому світі, правда це чи неправда
так, це неправда, тому що шаховий бокс - це
дуже дивний вид спорту, і він не такий
популярний, як футбол, наприклад
який найпопулярніший вид спорту
найпопулярніший вид спорту - це футбол
добре наступний американський футбол - це той самий
вид спорту, що і футбол правда це чи неправда,
звичайно, це неправда, тому що американський
футбол - це зовсім інший вид спорту
і останній, коли м'яч потрапляє
в сітку  ти забиваєш гол це правильно так
це правда добре давайте подивимося на це
речення трофей наш Кубек Неш
коли Академія взяла це це наш
трофей Макарова трофей наш
трофей для мене нове
Калама Казама це моя форма сер
Мойя  una forma рухатися через Того найбільше
над моєю буякою залишатися незайманою надія Рік
Метт Ніка Яков me forma mooyah Аламо
Момо Casati це моє сер Марія
це з'їсть Будду незайманий це я маніакально
це моє мій m  ousse mousse Casati
вони твої тренери кажуть 20 sport evening
cross it key a bomb emotions Casati
вони твої один це хвилюватися, що він отримає
Будду zemanick присвійні займенники
це його рекорд скажи, що ти hora
cADCA хлопець скажи, що ти кажеш, що це  її
пляшка з водою скажи, що він flash Косово робити війну
пляшка з водою її sebou Tilka ти
вони наші трофеї Nashik up key
a лук лук Nanashi bonnet nasha так Таня
це їхній сноуборд скажи якщо сноуборд
лук сноуборд їхній сноуборд він
намалював її бу  перестав відновити бюджет
мене ім'я О, Америка, мої боєприпаси
simonec мій твій
його будинок і ці слова
будуть дуже корисні для вас в
роздягальні ця лава Будда робити рокарії потрібні
лави Раста привіт Ніколь над Буддою
Шиката чи Реджі, коли ви
шукаю ваші речі, ваші речі,
запам'ятайте це
і потренуйтеся. Я дам вам трохи
попрактикуватися вдома, а тепер
наприкінці наших уроків давайте трохи
пограємо, добре, я не думаю, що час yes se cayó
just and y  вам слід записати стільки
слів про спорт, скільки ви знаєте, зрозуміло
так ACK, ми просто, якщо ми, Pavan, це Passat
Azad mcwillie no yakumo habilis, залишайте
не m-sport
добре, ви готові, я проти часу
три два один іду
[Музика]
[Музика  ]
добре три два одна зупинка
закінчіть, скільки слів у вас є, ви
можете позмагатися зі своєю матір'ю, братом,
сестрою, ліможом Махута каже, що плаваю,
мама, тата Мабус, трой, співжиття Браттона,
відходять, хто запише більше слів,
добре,
тому сьогодні на нашому уроці англійської мови  ми
багато дізналися про футбол футбол
є найпопулярнішим видом спорту в світі, ви
можете грати в нього на вулиці всередині, і навіть тут,
за цим столом, за допомогою цієї маленької гри, ми
дізналися, що у футбольній команді є 11 гравців,
ми дізналися, що
це футбольне поле або футбольне поле, ми
знаємо, що ця людина є воротарем, він
тримає ворота, ми дізналися, що
багато вболівальників або вболівальників підбадьорюють свою
команду, коли вони на стадіоні, і ми
практикуємо граматику, і ми знаємо, що
присутній  t continual — це час, який
описує дію, що відбувається
зараз, коли
і розмову, тож давайте практикувати
англійську та будьте здорові,
до побачення
[Музика]
ви